et il aurait voulu être là mais ça lui
était absolument impossible donc nous
avons le plaisir d'auditionner
aujourd'hui Madame Nathalie Loiseau
ancienne secrétaire d'État chargé des
affaires européennes désormais députés
européennes et présidente de la
sous-commission défense et sécurité du
Parlement européen et nous auditions
également Monsieur Raphaël luxmann
député européen président de la
Commission spéciale sur l'ingérence
étrangère dans l'ensemble des processus
démocratiques de l'Union européenne y
compris la désinformation et sur le
renforcement de l'intégrité de la
transparence et de la responsabilité du
Parlement européen madame Loiseau en
tant que membre de la délégation du
Parlement européen pour les relations
avec la république populaire de la Chine
nous nous demandons notamment si vous ou
vos collègues ont déjà fait avaient déjà
fait l'objet de pression au regard des
décisions prises par le Parlement
européen et d'autres institutions
européennes de bannir l'utilisation de
l'application Tik Tok en tant que
présidente de la sous-commission des
Français sécurité avez-vous par ailleurs
de a pas de raison de penser que Tik Tok
ou d'autres applications similaires
présentent des risques pour certains
aspects de la sécurité de l'Union
européenne monsieur luxmann lors de
votre audition le 4 avril dernier devant
la commission d'enquête de l'Assemblée
nationale relative aux ingérences des
puissances étrangères vous avez dénoncé
je vous cite la naïveté l'endolence et
la légèreté avec lesquels les dirigeants
ont abordé la question des ingérences
étrangères ces dernières années vous
pourrez aussi évoquer les résultats des
travaux de la Commission spéciale sur
l'ingérence étrangère du Parlement
européen que vous présidez vous
comprendrez que la stratégie qui nous
intéresse plus particulièrement
aujourd'hui et en la matière et celle de
la Chine dont l'ingérence aux indus
européenne est souvent analysé sous
l'angle de l'extra-territorialité du
droit et de sa politique
d'investissement étrangers dans des
secteurs de souveraineté de nos
démocraties
ainsi on regarde vos compétences et
connaissances respectives ainsi que des
informations et données auxquelles vous
avez eu accès nous aimerions être
éclairés aujourd'hui sur les principaux
modes opératoires de la Chine pour mener
des campagnes d'influence de
désinformation voire de déstabilisation
au cœur de nos démocraties européennes
quel serait selon vous les principaux
risques liés à l'utilisation de Tik Tok
et enfin comment pourrions-nous mieux
nous prémunir collectivement contre ces
menaces je rappelle que cette audition
est captée et retransmis en direct sur
le site du Sénat avant de laisser la
parole à Madame moiseau pierre monsieur
luxmann pour deux exposés diminuaires
d'une dizaine de minutes je vais
procéder au formalité d'usage pour les
commissions d'enquête et je dois ainsi
vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête et
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434 13 434 et 434 15 du code pénal je
vous invite à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité est la vérité en levant
la main droite et en disant je le jure
madame Loiseau
et bien cette formalité étant accomplie
vous pouvez commencer vos propos madame
Loiseau vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je voudrais
d'abord vous remercier pour votre
invitation à témoigner de votre devant
votre commission d'enquête
comme vous l'avez dit j'interviens avec
plusieurs casquettes devant vous
président de la sous-comission sécurité
et défense qui étudie l'ensemble des
menaces au sein de l'Union européenne et
la manière d'y répondre
des sujets qui sont souvent directement
militaires et c'est naturellement le cas
avec la guerre d'invasion russe en
Ukraine ou les missions militaires de
l'Union européenne à l'étranger mais
aussi les menaces hybrides et puisque
j'ai parlé de l'Ukraine l'Ukraine est un
bon exemple d'un pays qui a d'abord été
ciblé par des menaces hybrides qui fait
face aujourd'hui à une guerre
conventionnelle de haute intensité je
suis aussi coordinatrice de mon groupe
politique
au sein de la Commission spéciale sur
les ingérences qui est présidé par
Raphaël Glucksmann à ce titre je suis
actuellement co-rapporter du rapport
final de la commission spéciale qui se
penche plus particulièrement sur les
menaces d'ingérence contre le Parlement
européen lui-même vous avez tous entendu
parler du catarié mais
d'autres ingérences en particulier en
provenance de Russie et de Chine sont
sur notre radar depuis longtemps nous
les avons à la fois exposés et nous
formulons des recommandations pour nous
en protéger
ces deux casquettes que je viens de
décrire vont bien ensemble et d'ailleurs
les deux commissions celle de que
Raphaël Glucksman président travaillent
main dans la main au quotidien j'ai
d'ailleurs écrit un livre sur ces
menaces hybrides pour essayer de les
décrire et de faire des propositions et
comme vous l'avez dit je suis également
membre de la délégation aux relations
avec la Chine dans le Parlement européen
je dirais pour commencer que
il est important de mesurer le rôle des
plateformes en général comme outil
d'ingérence de puissance étrangère
toutes les plateformes et différentes
puissances étrangères on l'a vu en 2016
avec l'élection présidentielle
américaine à ce moment la plateforme qui
a été la plus utilisée pour ses
ingérences
a été Facebook
on l'a vu massivement avec la pandémie
de covid et depuis le début de la guerre
d'Ukraine ce sont toutes les plateformes
qui sont le relais de d'opérations de
manipulation de l'information on risque
le voir encore davantage l'année
prochaine 2024 est une année d'élection
dans beaucoup de pays elle commence en
janvier par Taïwan qui a le privilège
c'est j'ose dire d'ouvrir le bal
mais nous aurons également des élections
Royaume-Uni en Ukraine en Russie les
élections européennes et pour terminer
l'élection présidentielle américaine et
nous avons vu j'ai parlé de l'élection
présidentielle américaine de 2016 on
peut parler du référendum sur le brexit
que ces consultations électorales sont
fragiles vulnérables à des ingérences
étrangères
s'agissant des ingérences chinoises je
dirais qu'elle s’est lancée dans les
ingérences avec enthousiasme et avec le
poids que lui confère sa puissance
économique en apprenant des méthodes
russes et en apprenant vite
tout d'abord peut-être un rappel
l'ingérence et la manipulation de
l'information font partie de la doctrine
militaire chinoise elle-même qui
distingue l'existence de trois types de
guerre qui peuvent être menées par des
moyens non militaires la guerre de
l'opinion publique la guerre
psychologique et ce qu'on appelle le
l'offer
je me référerai aussi un article de
China de liquidate de décembre 2020 donc
qui est récent et on sait que China
Delhi n'écrit que ce qui est autorisé et
il écrit les médias numériques chinois
et russes devraient combattre ensemble
les attaques et les provocations des
pays occidentaux et mettre en place un
environnement international sain je cite
s'agissant de l'opinion publique nous
voilà donc prévenu
les ingérences de la Chine sont
maintenant bien établis elles passent
par diverses méthodes qu'il s'agisse de
la capture d'élite de l'intrusion via
des coopérations universitaires et
scientifiques du contrôle des diaspora
chinoises à l'étranger des cyberattaques
du financement de des activités de
certains Stans qui reviendrai
naturellement si vous avez des questions
mais le monde de l'Internet est un
terrain de jeu des ingérences chinoises
là aussi le paradoxe c'est que Pékin
exerce un contrôle social total sur
l'Internet en Chine ou les plateformes
occidentales sont bannies et où les
plateformes chinoises sont ultra
surveillées mais à l'étranger si j'ose
dire il s'agit d'une activité débridée
pendant le covid la désinformation sur
l'origine du virus ou sur les cités des
vaccins a souvent été made in China avec
des moyens considérables ce qu'on
appelle par exemple l'armée des 50
centimes c'est-à-dire au moins 2
millions de personnes qui en Chine sont
rémunérés pour
intervenir sur les réseaux sociaux
ces 2 millions de personnes on peut y
ajouter 20 millions de ce que
j'appellerai des trolls à temps partiel
là aussi si vous le souhaitez j'y
reviendrai plus en détail même les
comptes officiels du ministère des
Affaires étrangères chinoises le
whiterobu se sont fait les relais de
sites complotistes douteux par exemple
greason vous souvenez de l'intoxication
qui voulait que le virus du covid a été
créé en laboratoire aux États-Unis à
Fort de Netflix c'est un certain nombre
d'imagination puisque la même des
informations avaient été utilisées par
la Russie des années auparavant pour
accuser les États-Unis d'être à
l'origine du virus du sida
décidément font des trucs a beaucoup de
intéresse beaucoup de monde et si vous
tapez sur un moteur de recherche vous
trouverez en priorité de la
désinformation chinoise c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'usage des Data woids s'emparer
d'un sujet qui a été peu traité et le
saturer avec de la désinformation je
citerai aussi toujours sur le covid
l'invention d'un biologiste Suisse
imaginaire nommé Wilson Edwards qui
aurait là aussi eu des révélations à
faire sur le covid la Suisse a eu beau
protesté que cette biologiste n'existait
pas ces propos ont été repris par des
comptes officiels chinois depuis le
début de la guerre du crâne la
désinformation d'origine chinoise ne
s'est pas démenti elle reprend
systématiquement le narratif de la
Russie ce n'est pas une surprise compte
tenu du partenariat sans limite que chez
timping et Vladimir Poutine ont conclu
ensemble
alors sur Tik Tok qu'est-ce qu'on peut
en dire que c'est un instrument qui
permet toutes sortes de manipulations
c'est le cas d'autres plateformes mais
il y a quelques spécificités chinoises
qui doivent nous alerter tout d'abord le
format même des vidéos courtes de TikTok
qui permet d'engranger très vite
énormément de données sur les
utilisateurs de la plateforme des
données personnelles qui sont rapatriés
en Chine et on sait que des employés de
Tik Tok y ont accès puisque même Tic-Toc
adulte reconnaître notamment les données
de journalistes qui ont été précisément
sur Tik Tok ont été aspirés c'est donc
possible et c'est même obligatoire
puisqu'on connaît la loi de 2017 sur la
divers sécurité en Chine au-delà c'est
un outil d'influence qui émane d'un État
autoritaire qui ne nous laisse donc voir
que ce qui est validé et pas ce qui ne
l'est pas c'est un outil de propagande
d'une part et de censure d'autre part
propagande massive avec les influenceurs
qui répètent les mêmes éléments de
langage sur la plateforme et en revanche
des contenus
interdits lorsqu'il risquerait de
déplaire aux autorités de Pékin en
particulier sur ce qui relève des droits
de l'homme en Chine on sait aussi la
présence de cellules du Parti communiste
dans toutes les entreprises chinoises y
compris dans le bail dance là la maison
mère de TikTok et on se souvient des
mésaventures de Jack ma à la tête
d'Alibaba qui prouve que le patron d'une
entreprise dite privée mais de la tech
en Chine et soumis à de fortes pressions
politiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans
l'Union européenne nous nous sommes
dotés de réglementation qui elle couvre
toutes les plateformes et pas seulement
des plateformes chinoises sont des
vision transversale j'y reviendrai là
aussi si vous le souhaitez
essentiellement le rgpd et le DSA pour
répondre aux questions que vous m'avez
posées madame la Présidente est-ce que
nous avons fait l'objet de pression au
sein de la délégation pour les relations
avec la Chine depuis les décisions
prises dans l'Union européenne et
notamment au Parlement d'interdire Tik
Tok sur les outils professionnels des
personnels du Parlement européen je
dirais que la Chine se fait peu
d'illusions sur notre délégation au
point que son président
fait partie des personnes sanctionnées
par la Chine de même que Raphaël
Glucksmann que la sous commission des
droits de l'homme je crains d'être l'une
des rares personnes qui m'expriment pour
dénoncer le régime chinois à ne pas être
sanctionné non pas que je le réclame
mais c'est presque vexant c'est presque
vexant
peut-être parce que ou peut-être parce
que j'étais membre du gouvernement
d'Emmanuel Macron et que le couper s'est
arrêté juste avant moi je ne sais pas je
ne fais pas d'interprétation des pensées
profondes du régime de Pékin
donc nous avons peu de dialogues avec
l'ambassade de Chine
en revanche ce que je relève et là aussi
j'y reviendrai plus en détail si vous le
souhaitez c'est la montée en puissance
du lobbying de Tik Tok aux États-Unis
bien sûr on l'a vu au moment de
l'audition du patron de de Biden au
Congrès américain à Bruxelles en
parallèle mon groupe politique a
d'ailleurs demandé au patron de Tik Tok
de venir être auditionné au Parlement
européen nous n'avons pas de réponse
pour le moment sur les dangers de
sécurité de Tik Tok je crois les avoir
rapidement évoqués le fait que rien ne
permet de s'assurer aujourd'hui que les
données personnelles des utilisateurs et
notamment d'utilisateurs qui seraient je
dirais des ou potentiels politiques ou
des décideurs sont protégés par la
plateforme
la plateforme nous assure que jamais
elle n'a rien transmis aux autorités
chinoises des autorités chinoises nous
promettent que jamais elles n'ont rien
demandé mais les promesses n'engagent
que ceux qui les écoutent et
de contrôle
irlandaise a déclenché deux enquêtes sur
des violations possibles du rgpd par Tik
Tok donc première préoccupation deuxième
préoccupation je l'ai dit outils
d'influence de désinformation je
relèverai simplement que le groupe
Wagner est présent sur Tik Tok
et n'est pas sanctionné
que par ailleurs tout ce qui risque de
déplaire à la Chine en est absent cela
suffit à le voir comme une arme
d'influence de la Chine à son profit
dans nos démocraties
merci madame la Présidente et merci à
l'ensemble de la commission pour
l'invitation
quelques mots d'abord sur la Commission
spéciale sur les ingérences étrangères
et dès le début de notre mandature j'ai
demandé la création d'une telle
commission parce qu'il me semblait que
nous faisions preuve d'une naïveté
confondante à l'égard de régime en
particulier de régime autoritaire qui
s'ingérait dans nos élections dans notre
débat public dans notre vie publique et
qui n'était jamais ni sanctionné ni même
confronté et qu'il fallait si nous
voulions être sérieux dans la défense de
notre souveraineté et de notre sécurité
et de nos démocraties et bien d'abord
établir un diagnostic général savoir qui
nous attaque comment quels sont les
failles de nos systèmes de défense et
sur la base de ce diagnostic général et
bien
émettre des recommandations pour mieux
protéger nos démocraties
et mieux faire face à ces attaques cette
commission elle a été finalement créée
en septembre 2020 et depuis nous
travaillons d'ailleurs main dans la main
avec Nathalie Loiseau et avec la plupart
des groupes politiques du Parlement nous
avons un fonctionnement très
transpartisan dans cette commission
parce que il en va de la défense de
notre bien commun qui est la démocratie
et qui est le cadre si vous voulez de
l'expression de nos dissensus sur le
reste mais ce cadre là il est menacé et
on a pu et finalement comprendre que
c'est ingérences elles
elles utilisent différentes méthodes et
je vais entrer dans le détail ensuite
mais les différentes méthodes c'est la
capture des élites et notamment des
élites politiques mais pas seulement
notamment le fait que la Chine et la
Russie soit devenue au fil des années
les pourvoyeurs de retraite dorée de nos
élus de nos gouvernants ou de nos
responsables d'institutions
vous connaissez tous le cas de Garges
schrowder évidemment pour Gazprom il
faut comprendre que que ça ça a une
influence énorme parce que garage
Schroder ensuite à piloté finalement le
revirement de la politique énergétique
allemande donc européenne tout cela au
service de gaz Prom et qui n'était pas
le seul et qui a même un terme qui a été
inventé en Russie qui s'appelle
la classe politique c'est à dire la
transformation de la classe politique
européenne en supermarché et
les Chinois évidemment ce sont largement
inspirés des pratiques russes sur cette
question la capture des élites donc
la manipulation de l'information pour
influencer notre débat public sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment mais pas
uniquement
le les investissements dans nos secteurs
stratégiques le financement de mouvement
politique ou d'ONG de think tank qui
repose sur l'absence de transparence
dans beaucoup de d'États membres bref
tout un panoplie d'outils qui sont
utilisés pour deux finalités et là on
distingue les différents types
d'ingérence il y a ce que j'appellerais
les ingérences dites classiques c'est à
dire qu'un État étranger décide
d'utilité d'utiliser des outils
d'influence pour faire en sorte que soit
on prenne des décisions qui lui sont
favorables soit on s'abstiennent des
mettre des critiques et soit on signe
des accords qui
jugent extrêmement bénéfique ça c'est
finalement une ingérence classique qui a
toujours existé et c'est notamment le
cas du Maroc et du Qatar sur la question
du Qatar gate ou du Maroc gate c'est à
dire on va utiliser la corruption pour
obtenir une décision favorable ou une
absence de critique à l'égard du Qatar
ou du Maroc
il y a une autre forme d'un gérance
cette haute forme d'ingérence elle ne
vise pas tant à pousser l'intérêt de
l'État qui s'ingère mais à déstabiliser
nos démocraties et cette autre forme
d'ingérence elle était d'abord portée
par la Russie elle a quasiment été
façonnée inventé par la Russie c'est un
gérant séduise au chaos par exemple
c'est pas faire la pub de la Russie sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est soutenir les
pôles les plus extrêmes du débat public
dans nos pays dans le but de rendre
notre débat public chaotique c'est par
exemple le fait que les campagnes russes
on en a disséquées ensemble des dizaines
et bien puissent soutenir des campagnes
des trolls russes de l'Internet reser
chez Johns Saint-Pétersbourg par exemple
puis soutenir à la fois les
indépendantistes qui Attalens et les
ultras nationalistes castillants
les deux pôles les plus opposés du débat
public en Espagne à la fois black life
matters et
Olive matters à la fois les gens qui
dénoncent les violences policières en
France et les gens qui demandent qu'on
tire dans la foule les deux en même
temps donc il y a pas de principe de
contradiction là le but est la
déstabilisation et la radicalisation
permanente du débat public dans les
démocraties occidentales pendant
longtemps la Chine parce que c'est
l'objet de la Commission et de
l'audition la Chine était plutôt
dans une forme d'ingérence classique
même si massive et il y a eu des moments
de bascule et depuis la pandémie il
semble désormais évident que la Chine a
adopté le modèle russe et d'ailleurs
quand on doute c'est une aparté mais
quand on doute de la solidité de
l'alliance entre Pékin et Moscou il
suffit en fait de voir sur le terrain
sur le terrain de la guerre hybride
quels sont les attitudes des uns et des
autres pour comprendre que cette
alliance pour le moment est absolument
solide c'est à dire que les narratifs
comme Nathalie vient de le dire les
narratifs russes sont totalement repris
poussés par les agents chinois et
finalement il y a une conjonction parce
qu'il y a un objectif commun qui est la
déstabilisation de nos démocraties et
l'affaiblissement des institutions
européennes c'est une évidence quand on
part du terrain de des actions pas quand
on parle nécessairement des discours qui
sont tenus même si les discours vont
dans le même sens
la question des ingériens Chinoises il y
a une spécificité par rapport à la
Russie même c'est que les Russes ont
clairement développé des techniques plus
avancées et ont un objectif chaos encore
plus assumé mais il y a des spécificités
par exemple vous avez posé la question
de du lobbying ou des pressions moi ce
qui me frappe au Parlement européen ou
dans les institutions européennes ou
dans le débat public en général quand
vous êtes un décideur dans les
institutions nationales aussi c'est que
le gouvernement chinois a pas tant
besoin que ça dans d'engager des
lobbistes pourquoi parce que la Chine
contrairement aux autres pays là par
contre peut compter sur le travail des
entreprises européennes et là ça c'est
un vrai problème c'est à dire qu'en fait
on est devenu tellement dépendant du
marché chinois et de l'appareil
productif chinois que nos grands groupes
parce qu'il dépendent de la Chine
devienne si vous voulez des lobbistes
des ambassades bis du gouvernement
chinois et donc quand on doit apprendre
une décision sur le marché intérieur sur
le bannissement des produits de
l'esclavage sur même le l'accord
d'investissement entre l'Union
européenne et la Chine et bien les gens
qui défilent dans nos bureaux sont
beaucoup plus les représentants de
Volkswagen que du gouvernement chinois
lui-même parce que finalement les
intérêts sont conjoints et qui est une
forme de pacte faussien entre ces grands
groupes et le Parti communiste chinois
ça peut sembler bizarre sur le papier
mais c'est comme ça que ça se fait dans
les couloirs du parlement européen et
donc
pour comprendre les ingérences chinoises
il faut comprendre la dépendance aussi
européenne vis-à-vis de la Chine et les
deux sont intimement liés pourquoi c'est
un problème que par exemple des
ministres d'anciens ministres français à
y travailler pour Huawei alors que ce
serait sans doute moins un problème
s'ils allaient travailler pour une
entreprise norvégienne ou brésilienne
bien parce que en Russie comme en Chine
le la notion de grande entreprise privée
n'est pas du tout du tout du tout la
même que chez nous et by dance n'est pas
une entreprise privée comme on l'entend
ici bien sûr que c'est une entreprise
privée sur le papier mais en Russie
comment Chine il est impossible pour une
entreprise qui dépasse une taille
critique d'échapper au contrôle du
régime politique
et donc quand vous avez une taille plus
que critique comme by dance et ben vous
êtes soumis non seulement à la loi la
loi de 2017
qui soumet les acteurs tous les acteurs
institutionnels privés y compris
aux exigences de sécurité nationale
émises par le Parti communiste chinois
mais vous êtes aussi soumis au diktat
politique
plus que légal créé par un écosystème
qui soumet l'ensemble des acteurs privés
aux objectifs affichés par le pouvoir
politique et vous êtes aussi soumis dans
la structure de propriété vous
connaissez tous la pratique des Golden
share du Parti communiste chinois donc
la présence dans les instances décisions
des entreprises privées des
représentants du Parti communiste
chinois et ça pose un problème terrible
parce qu'en fait quand on parle de naïf
et européenne c'est que pendant très
longtemps on a dit mais enfin où est le
problème il s'agit d'entreprises privées
pourquoi ne pas confier la 5gr Huawei
c'était ça le débat en empire si l'offre
est la meilleure les sondes les logiques
du marché décidé
c'est le problème c'est que en fait
quand vous avez un acteur qui à
l'intérieur n'applique pas les logiques
du marché appliquez les pures logiques
du marché chez vous c'est mettre en
danger votre sécurité nationale et
laisser la pénétration étrangère et bien
sapé les bases de votre souveraineté et
donc si on en vient spécifiquement à la
question de Tik Tok Nathalie Loiseau a
déjà
évoqué les risques mais il y a
un événement quand même enfin les TikTok
leaks qui ont montré à quel point
l'accès
à l'information était non seulement
possible mais réalisé pour les services
chinois parce qu'en fait la question des
serveurs bien sûr que la question de la
location enfin le lieu des serveurs est
extrêmement important mais en réalité
mettre les serveurs en Europe ne
changera rien parce qu'il y aura
toujours un accès à la question de
l'accès le problème et la question de
l'accès par les autorités chinoises
serveurs même s'ils sont placés en
Europe et bien
elle n'est pas résolue cette question là
et nous savons que il y a des donc grâce
à ceelix mais ensuite ça a été reconnu
même qu'il y a des enquêtes qui ont été
menées enfin des intrusions qui ont été
faites et donc il y a la question des
données il y a aussi la question une
question simple pourquoi est-ce qu'une
entreprise qui est une application qui
est aussi perfectionnée techniquement
technologiquement n'a pas de
d'identification multifacteur ça c'est
une vraie question que pose tous les
services de sécurité enfin même ceux du
Parlement c'est-à-dire que en fait on a
laissé des des facilités de pénétration
qui n'existent pas nécessairement dans
les autres applications et donc il y a
un risque là de Tik Tok ensuite il y a
le risque que tu as évoqué de la
désinformation sur Tik Tok et là dessus
il y a des études qui ont été faites et
Tik Tok était moins pro par exemple si
on prend les mi-temps aux États-Unis à
lutter contre les phénomènes des
informations qui devenaient viraux que
d'autres comme méta ou Youtube même si
encore une fois franchement il y a
aucune plateforme qui est vraiment très
exemplaire là-dessus mais dans le cas de
Tik Tok c'était jugé encore plus faible
donc en fait il y a une conjugaison de
risque
et donc la question qui se pose à nous
c'est que
finalement on doit tirer les leçons de
l'absence de prise en compte des risques
vous savez pendant très longtemps on a
cru que laisser des stocks stratégiques
gaziers allemands sur le territoire
allemand à gaz Rome c'était finalement
c'était un jeu du marché c'était pas
très dangereux la réalité c'est que
au lendemain de l'invasion totale de
l'Ukraine quand monsieur abbek ministre
allemand découvre que les stocks gérés
par Gazprom en Allemagne ont été vidés
pendant les six mois qui précédaient la
guerre ce qui veut dire que nous
Européens sommes contraints d'augmenter
nos importations en pleine guerre de
l'énergie de Brucie et bien on se rend
compte qu'on a été naïf donc là l'enjeu
c'est de ne plus prendre ce type de
risque
l'enjeu c'est de placer des
considérations de sécurité et de
souveraineté au dessus des pures
logiques de marché et garder en tête
dans vos travaux encore une fois la
spécificité des régimes c'est
fondamental vous avez en Chine et en
Russie des régimes tout puissants qui
font que les structures privées leur
obéissent et que donc
quelque chose qui est pareil sur le
papier qu'en Europe ne donne pas du tout
les mêmes résultats et ne se traduit pas
du tout de la même manière et voilà
maintenant ça fait disposer à répondre à
vos questions et j'espère que je n'ai
pas été trop long
je vais d'abord donner la parole pour
rapporteur Claude malloret pour
compléter par une série de questions
j'imagine
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente et
merci à tous les deux d'abord d'avoir
accepté la gravitation et puis de cette
exposé de ces deux exposés préliminaires
tout à fait
pertinent et intéressant je voudrais
vous dire qu'on se réjouit de vous
recevoir aujourd'hui pour différentes
raisons mais je voudrais
particulièrement je pense que ça c'est
inutile pour les banques de cette
commission mais attirer l'attention je
suppose que tout le monde était au même
niveau d'information que moi sur les
deux ouvrages que vous avez récemment
publiés Nathalie il y a quelques mois et
Raphaël Griezmann plus récemment et qui
me paraissent tout important et qui sont
en très très en relation et corrélé avec
le ce dont nous
occupons aujourd'hui dans cette
commission
Raphaël Laurence rossinacité tout à
l'heure Raphaël kluxmann d'ailleurs il
s'est exprimé là-dessus sur le thème de
la naïveté confondant de l'un de Lens et
de la légèreté des
une démocratie occidentale par rapport
à tous les problèmes posés par les
régimes totalitaires aujourd'hui et les
régimes dictatoriaux c'est évidemment
une des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai
souhaité que cette demander au Sénat de
de se prononcer sur l'établissement de
cette commission je suis heureux qu'il
l'ait fait mais bien entendu
je vous rejoins je voudrais juste citer
une anecdote que Catherine Morin duci
se rappellera très probablement
en ce qui concerne la naïveté j'ai
proposé en 2018 dans la commission de
culture aussi où était reçu le ministre
Cédric o de d'interdire en France 2018
je crois que j'ai dit 2018 pardon merci
d'interdire RT et Sputnik
Cédrico a levé les bras au ciel en
disant que nous nous n'étions pas des
dictatures et que c'est un problème de
liberté d'exploitation j'ai eu beau lui
dire que la liberté d'expression
s'appliquait aux médias mais pas
obligatoirement aux officines de
désinformation
issues du directeur ad du FSB mais je
n'ai pas eu je n'ai pas eu gain de cause
et je suis passé pour celui qui luttait
contre la liberté le 24 février la
naïveté c'est un petit peu 24 février
2022 la naïveté c'est un petit peu
abaissé et enfin on a supprimé ces
organes de propagande
je voudrais vous poser quelques
questions pas trop parce que je pense
que mes collègues en ont beaucoup
d'autres
la première question
c'est la Commission européenne depuis le
Parlement européen puis un certain
nombre de
gouvernement après les États-Unis et
Canada mais le gouvernement européen ont
décidé d'interdire à leur fonctionnaires
le téléchargement de l'applique
c'est je dirais c'est à la fois trop
épaissé parce que ou bien on considère
qu'il y a un danger de Tik Tok et dans
ces conditions on interdit tout
simplement
commercer et cosmoutique pour des
raisons d'espionnage de transfert de
données etc et on recommande au
gouvernement européen de l'interdire
purement et simplement ou bien
il n'y a pas de de raison évidente de
l'interdire aux fonctionnaires si on ne
dit pas pourquoi or et c'est là que
s'ouvre la boîte de Pandore
la Commission européenne n'a pas du tout
expliqué
si ce n'est façon
à l'usive sur les transferts de données
sans doute pour ne pas vexer le
gouvernement chinois en parlant
d'espionnage mais pour le moment la
Commission et les gouvernements
européens ont interdit à leur
fonctionnaires au téléchargement de
l'application
et encore leur fonctionnaires régalien
pour la plupart et pas tous les
fonctionnaires
sans donner de raison alors ma première
question c'est la suivante est-ce que
vous avez ou quelqu'un au Parlement ou
alcoviseur a posé la question et nous
nous comptons bien la poser si on n'a
pas de réponse d'ici là aux responsables
de la Commission européenne au
commissaire européen
pourquoi a-t-on
interdit le téléchargement de
l'application en fonctionnaire et
pourquoi ne dit-on pas pourquoi
donc ma question c'est est-ce que au
sein de la Commission européenne du
Parlement cette question a été posée
est-ce que vous avez eu des réponses
est-ce qu'il y a eu des réponses de la
part des responsables de la Commission
européenne ou du Parlement
la deuxième question oui et d'ailleurs
je voudrais rajouter une chose pour la
petite histoire c'est qu'alors que tout
que la Commission le Parlement et tous
les gouvernements européens ont interdit
le téléchargement de l'application
TikTok alors fonctionnait le
gouvernement français qui évidemment
n'est pas n'importe quel gouvernement et
qui a toujours ses spécificités n'est-ce
pas y compris par rapport aux relations
avec nos alliés
c'est pas contenter d'interdire
l'application TikTok sur les smartphones
de leur fonctionnaires mais interdit le
chargement de plusieurs applications
dont Netflix dont je me rappelle plus
lesquels etc donc je voudrais voir votre
sentiment là-dessus parce que est-ce que
vous pensez que cette décision était
justifiée l'interdiction de télécharger
Netflix sur les smartphones ou est-ce
que vous pensez qu'à quelques jours de
la visite puisque cette décision était
prise il y a une quinzaine de jours qui
a quelques jours de la du président
Macron en Chine c'était destiné à ne pas
cibler plus particulièrement une
application et une plateforme chinoise
ma question suivante
vous avez un peu vous l'avez un peu
abordé
c'est que Tik Tok évidemment nous assure
qu'ils n'ont qu'il n'y a aucun lien avec
la Chine avec le gouvernement chinois
etc et que d'ailleurs le capital
aujourd'hui est réparti et largement
majoritairement non chinois il explique
d'ailleurs que la preuve c'est que
le siège de Gilles caïmans moi si
j'étais à leur place je prendrais pas
comme exemple de transparence le fait
d'avoir
établi mon siège aussi le caïman parce
que ça va être un petit peu compliqué de
savoir s'ils disent la vérité dans cet
appartition du capital mais quoi qu'il
en soit ils disent il y a pas de lien
avec le en chinois quand et la maison
mère ce que nous appelons la maison mère
mais qu'il n'appelle pas la maison mère
bike n'est pas majoritaire dans son
capital alors c'est un cette
cette déclaration étant étant qui a été
répété d'ailleurs au Congrès lorsque
sous-titchou a été auditionné par les
membres du Congrès américain et
directement contredite par le
gouvernement chinois
probablement d'ailleurs à son insu ou
sans l'avoir voulu puisque lorsque les
Américains sugèrent de vendre que
l'application Tik Tok soit vendue à des
sociétés américaines pour ne plus avoir
les risques
inhérents à la situation actuelle le
gouvernement chinois dit il n'en est pas
question nous devront jamais TikTok nous
ne laisserons jamais Tic-Toc vendre ce
qui est la preuve même que c'est bien le
gouvernement chinois qui
qui
mène le jeu si je peux dire donc je
voulais vous demander si vous avez
au-delà des deux facteurs qui sont
évidemment ceux de toutes les grandes
sociétés chinoises d'abord apprendre à
la moindre énormément de services de
renseignement chinois deuxièmement
d'avoir une cellule du PC chinois dans
dans le mais c'est pas le cas de Tik Tok
directement est-ce que vous avez quel
est votre sentiment de façon plus plus
précise sur les rapports
entre la société non pas entre la
société mais entre la société Tik Tok et
même et le gouvernement chinois est-ce
que par un moyen ou pas un autre ou par
des successions de moyens
il est important pour nous d'établir le
degré moi je suis assez persuadé que est
assez fort mais d'établir de façon la
plus précise possible degré de
d'affiliation de ces sociétés au
gouvernement et aux parties communistes
chinois s'il n'est pas tout à fait la
même chose mais
je voudrais vous poser une question sur
vous en avez parlé aussi donc sur les
établissement de serveur en Europe le
projet Texas aux États-Unis et le projet
Clover en Europe
je vais pas vous poser une question
technique parce que la question
technique nous nous devons d'ailleurs
déjà posé à des informations à des
sociétés spécialisées il nous paraît
d'ailleurs à la suite de ces auditions
assez évident que le projet Clover
d'abord il est question d'installer les
serveurs dans deux pays européens qui
sont très particuliers le premier c'est
l'Irlande qui pour des raisons fiscales
etc ne joue pas systématiquement le jeu
de l'ensemble des autres pays européens
et le deuxième c'est le Russe qui n'est
pas un pays européen au sens qu'il
n'appartient pas à l'Union européenne ce
qui déjà pose des problèmes sur le choix
de ces deux de ces deux pays
il paraît évident à suivre des auditions
que nous avons eu qu'il n'est pas
possible d'éviter les portes dérobées et
que quand vous le tout à l'heure de
toute façon à partir du moment où les
données doivent être traitées un certain
nombre de données doivent être traitées
en Chine par des ingénieurs chinois on
voit pas comment ils pourraient en être
autrement mais
la
question que je voulais vous poser n'est
pas une question technique c'est une
question politique puisque vous êtes là
à titre politique
quel est aujourd'hui au sein du
Parlement et de la Commission européenne
la sensibilité sur ou
sur le fait d'accepter ou non de
recommander ou non le projet Clover
est-ce que vous pensez que la Commission
européenne est susceptible de d'accepter
ce projet de le recommander il est
d'ailleurs déjà il est d'ailleurs
particulièrement opaque même à ce stade
quel est votre sentiment sur la que sera
la position demain du Parlement européen
et de la Commission européenne sur le
projet Clover
question suivante et celle de
l'interdiction ou de la régulation
depuis qu'on a créé cette commission
ta journaliste qui viennent nous voir et
la première question qui pose c'est
alors est-ce que vous allez interditif
toc nous on se reçoit la question comme
ça on se pose d'abord la question de
savoir qu'est-ce que c'est du cloque
qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans ce dans ce mécanisme d'essayer de
l'ouvrir un peu et ensuite d'en tirer
des conclusions qui peuvent être de
toute nature on n'est pas là on n'a pas
créé cette commission pour dire on va
interdire Tic-Toc mais il n'en reste pas
moins que sur ce sujet se pose d'ores et
déjà avant même toute conclusion de deux
problèmes
le premier problème c'est celui de la
réciprocité est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il est possible
durablement que les plateformes
occidentales soient interdites purement
et simplement en Chine
et contrepartie la Chine fait ce qu'elle
veut je lui dis tout à l'heure sur les
plateformes occidentales et qu'en plus
les
Occidentaux laissent la Chine développer
n'importe quelle plateforme parce que
Tik Tok n'est pas la seule peut-être il
est peut-être à mon avis en tout cas
wechat qui s'occupe qui qui se qui ne
s'adresse pas à nous mais qui s'adresse
à toutes les communautés chinoises dans
le monde entier c'est-à-dire quelque
chose de extrêmement énorme et qui est
peut-être de ce point-là plus
problématique que Tik Tok nous laissons
tous là
alors première question est-ce qu'à
titre de non pas de
comment dire de
de menaces d'espionnage ou autre de
transfert de données mais à titre de
d'équilibre politique et commercial
est-ce qu'il vous paraît normal et
est-ce que d'être dans cette situation
et qu'est-ce que vous recommanderiez de
ce point de vue là le deuxième
point par rapport à l'interdiction ou
régulation si on dit on n'interdit pas
Tik Tok à la fin de la conclusion et que
il faut probablement
envisager une à ce moment-là le problème
de la régulation est-ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui que le DMA le DSH je crois
que Natalie on a dit deux mots tout à
l'heure parce que vous pensez que le DMA
est le DSA sont des outils suffisants
pour réguler d'ailleurs pas seulement
Tik Tok mais d'autres plateformes mais
nous on s'occupe des Tik Tok ou est-ce
que vous pensez et est-ce que le
Parlement européen et la Commission sont
aujourd'hui en train de se pencher
d'ores et déjà parce que les choses
évoluent évidemment beaucoup plus
rapidement que le législateur à chaque
fois sont déjà en train de se pencher
sur
les nécessités les futures nécessité de
la régulation par rapport à ses
platoires mais notamment par rapport à
Tik Tok
et enfin je voudrais vous poser une
dernière question
aucune plateforme est exemplaire sur le
plan
des données de l'algorithme disait
Raphaël Luxman tout à l'heure
[Musique]
j'avais
le Sénat le Français a voté il y a deux
ans et là aussi mes collègues s'en
souviennent sans doute contre la vie du
gouvernement un amendement à la loi sur
le séparatisme qui disait la chose
suivante c'est un moment que j'avais
proposé dans je ne vais jamais pensé
qu'il serait voté
et qu'il a été à l'unanimité contre la
vie du gouvernement disons toute
plateforme qui
[Musique]
je me rappelle plus les termes
catégorise cette diffusion
d'informations à partir
d'algorithmes ou d'autres traitements
informatiques analogue
entraîne un choix dans et qui se prétend
hébergeur
et qui nous dit et qui dit je ne suis
pas un éditeur puisque je ne me contente
de diffuser c'est d'ailleurs tout le
lobbying début des gafam à Bruxelles qui
dépense des milliards pour essayer
d'éviter quand les désigne comme
producteur et non pas comme hébergeur
donc toute plateforme qui fait de la
curelation au sens anglais du terme
c'est à dire qui trie les informations
que ce soit à partir d'algorithmes à
partir d'autres outils informatiques
déterminent par le même une ligne
éditoriale et devient des facto un
éditeur et non pas un hébergeur et de ce
point de vue là et comme le dit Thierry
Breton ce qui doit être ce qui est
interdit offline online et la modération
de doit se faire
préalablement et non pas expost
cette la vie du gouvernement était pour
le par le même ministre et pour les
mêmes ce qui est de la liberté
d'expression le contraire mais le Sénat
a voté à l'énergie évidemment il n'est
jamais passé à l'Assemblée nationale que
je voudrais vous demander ce que vous
pensez sur cette diffusion sur cette
distinction entre éditeur et
diffuseur et si vous pensez qu'on peut
longtemps continuer avec des plateformes
pas seulement Tik Tok mais les
plateformes qui continuent sur ce thème
de pouvoir diffuser ce à peu près ce
qu'elles veulent modéré avec une
insuffisance criante et encore plus
vivante chez Tik Tok que chez les autres
ou s'il va falloir quand même et
notamment au niveau européen régler cela
je vous remercie je m'excuse à mon tour
d'avoir été sans doute plus long que je
ne le souhaitais
je vais vous donner la parole dans un
instant à prendre prendra les questions
parce que comme le président madurée a
déjà bien été fourni dans ces questions
à votre égard moi je voudrais en
rajouter peut-être une à cet instant
j'avais les mêmes questions sur la
réciprocité
elle est abordée
je n'avais une c'est effectivement vous
allez peut-être y répondre c'est comment
comment on identifie la nationalité le
Tik Tok voilà mais je crois que la poser
et enfin une autre c'est quel est
l'accès des Chinois TikTok est-ce que
les chinois ont un accès
voilà comment les Chinois qu'est-ce que
les Chinois voient sur Tik Tok voilà et
enfin sur hébergeur diffuseur je
confirme et j'appuie la question dans la
mesure où pour travailler sur la
diffusion des contenus pornographiques
nous avons exactement le même problème
sur les contenus pornographiques et si
vous avez un mot nous dire sur Tik Tok
et des contenus pornographiques nous
sommes au moins deux à être preneuse et
probablement tous nos collègues aussi
trois enfin bon à tous les collègues
présents dans la salle qui commence
je vais essayer d'être très très rapide
et
toute façon ce qui est bien c'est que je
peux compter sur Nathalie pour être
exhaustive derrière
aujourd'hui le
les mesures qui sont prises c'est la
vraie question pourquoi et pourquoi il y
a pas de pourquoi
elles sont pas expliquées et ensuite je
m'expliquerai sur enfin je m'exprimerai
sur Netflix
alors nous on a reçu une note
confidentielle voilà partager mais je
sais pas le droit de le faire
publiquement qui explique les risques
elle a pas été communiquée publiquement
d'ailleurs ça c'est une vraie question
c'est à dire
c'est de toute façon une mesure de
précaution
c'est à dire que c'est fondé sur l'idée
de risques c'est pas fondé sur
sur
des preuves
d'espionnage
avérées même si on a
ces risques sont conséquents et le fait
de ne pas les partager à mon avis
et problématique politiquement
démocratiquement et relève d'une
politique européenne depuis longtemps
qui est de ne pas
antagoniser la Chine et je pense que
cette politique est
porté à sa quintessence avec la décision
du gouvernement français sur Netflix
parce que tout ce que nous on essaye
d'expliquer dans la commission spéciale
c'est quand même que oui il faut des
critères objectifs et généraux il s'agit
pas de faire comme les américains et de
cibler à chaque fois spécifiquement
la Chine le gouvernement chinois une
région en Chine mais
il s'agit quand même pas non plus de
faire semblant que Netflix et Tik Tok
pose les mêmes problèmes
et je pense que c'est d'ailleurs
une faille dans le raisonnement européen
que l'on retrouve à chaque étape de
notre commission spéciale
l'absence de volonté ou la volonté de ne
pas faire de liste par exemple d'entités
problématiques pour notre souveraineté
notre sécurité
conduit à des réflexions parfois
lunaires parce qu'elle s'impose un
caractère universel et indestin dans les
cibles
comment faire pour réglementer je vais
prendre un exemple qui n'est pas la
question des plateformes mais vous avez
comprendre ce que ça produit en fait
comme type de réflexion comment faire
pour réglementer les travaux que des
sénateurs ou des députés ou des
ministres vont faire après leur mandat
ou leur rôle
on est là dans une réflexion en
particulier après le catargate qui qui
est extrêmement intense et on parle de
cette cooling of période de cette
période de refroidissement ou chacun
devra s'abstenir d'aller travailler pour
telle ou tel intérêt privé le problème
c'est que travailler pour gaz propane et
travailler pour une entreprise
norvégienne
boire c'est pas la même chose
c'est pas la même chose et c'est traité
de la même manière donc là on a on a un
peu un problème c'est à dire que les
services de sécurité ils vont nous
alerter sur Gazprom plus que sur la
question de l'entreprise de bois en
Norvège mais si on traite tout de
manière universelle si on fait pas
spécifiquement quelque chose sur
gasproom et bien on va se retrouver très
rapidement dans des discussions qui
peuvent conduire à des aporis parce que
en gros si c'est on interdit à tout
officiel ou à tout serviteur de l'État
d'aller travailler dans une entreprise
privée toute sa vie on va avoir un
problème de recrutement dans les
entreprises dans l'état et voilà il y
aura plus que des fonctionnaires et je
comprends qu'il y aurait quand même une
forme de d'insurrection morale face au
fait qu'on paye toutes leurs vies des
gens parce qu'ils ont été ministre
pendant un an
ça posera un problème et donc en même
temps on peut pas les faire mourir de
faim non plus donc qu'est-ce qui se
passe et bien
[Musique]
donc il y a une mesure de précaution et
qui et qui quand elle est étendue à
Netflix perd un peu de son sens à mon
humble invisible c'est à vie si vous
voulez que je vous réponde franchement
quand le gouvernement chinois j'allais
vous mais vous avez mis dans la question
la réponse
quand le gouvernement chinois dit nous
ne laisserons pas faire ça veut dire
qu'en fait la structure officielle de
propriété de Tik Tok ne reflète en rien
le processus de décision
et c'est tout le problème de ces régimes
opaque c'est que vous pouvez très bien
avoir sur le papier une structure de
propriété qui est majoritairement à
l'extérieur de la Chine
il n'empêche que dans le fonctionnement
c'est le gouvernement chinois le Parti
communiste chinois qui va décider des
orientations qui seront prises ou qui ne
seront pas prises
et la même chose ressort des 80 réunions
qui ont été
enregistrées et qui ont donné lieu au
Tik Tok clicks c'est que dans bossfield
c'est qu'en fait
la pratique est la vérité ça doit être
ça la base de notre approche la pratique
de gastrom et la vérité de gasproom pas
la structure officielle la pratique de
Tik Tok elle a la vérité Tik Tok donc
sur le papier ça peut très bien devenir
une entreprise européenne basée en
Irlande la question c'est qui commande
concrètement réellement et là-dessus
vous pouvez avoir toutes les garanties
sur le papier il y aura toujours le la
même suspicion parce que on ne refuse
rien aux autorités politiques chinoises
et que les exemples qui sont faits parlé
d'Alibaba tout à l'heure font que de
personnes ne leur refusera rien qui a
des liens avec la Chine et qui donc est
forcément dépendant de la bonne volonté
du pouvoir politique sur les serveurs
encore une fois vraiment j'insiste c'est
le lieu des serveurs
et moins important que la question de
l'accès au serveur et de l'accès au data
et là-dessus c'est pareil c'est la
pratique qui décide sur et je veux pas
répondre à tout parce que je vais être
en trop long l'interdiction la
régulation c'est la grande question
moi je peux juste vous livrer là mon
point de vue personnel je pense pas
qu'on en soit aujourd'hui au moment où
on va bannir Tik Tok de l'ensemble du
continent européen ça sera pas ça qui
sera décidé par contre
il y a des questions de régulation et il
y a des questions de réciprocité vous
les avez mentionnés et le fait est que
on risque d'arriver à ce bannissement
parce que il y a une un déséquilibre
total
dans nos relations avec la Chine c'est
vrai du commerce et c'est vrai de
l'information c'est d'ailleurs on se met
dans une position
c'est la même chose avec la Russie ou en
gros il y a un contrôle absolu de toute
influence qui pourrait émaner de nos
démocraties en Chine et que nous on n'a
pas du tout la même attitude c'est tout
à notre honneur mais ça doit pas devenir
finalement une naïveté sur les
algorithmes là je voudrais juste être un
tout petit peu plus long là dessus sur
les algorithmes sur votre amendement
je pense que c'est fondamental
et là dessus je veux juste expliquer
pourquoi et ça concerne pas que Tik Tok
là par contre
les les algorithmes des plateformes
qui sont les secrets les mieux gardés de
ces plateformes
finalement
cherche quoi à maximiser votre présence
sur la plateforme à vous attirer à vous
exciter à vous rendre dépendant et donc
on l'a vu par exemple ce qui a été
révélé des émoticônes sur facebook quand
la colère et 5 fois plus mise en avant
que l'approbation parce que la colère
est plus addictive et bien c'est ces
algorithmes qui dictent qui sont les
lois en fait de notre nouvelle Agora et
ça c'est tout le paradoxe c'est qu'en
fait notre notre débat public a
désormais lieu dans un espace privé
de comprendre ce que ça suppose voilà
c'est l'opposé de la place publique donc
en fait on est notre place publique est
devenu un espace privé notre Agora est
un lieu privé régi par des lois que le
décideur public
que le législateur ne connaît pas
et c'est lois c'est ça l'enjeu des
algorithmes et c'est lois et bien
favorise les branlements de notre
démocratie
parce que c'est loi favorise les
opinions les plus polarisantes et les
addicts et rend addicts
drogués au point de vue de la colère et
donc là on a une recette pour une
catastrophe
et
le régime russe ce qui on a plus accès
alors réflexion théorique là-dessus le
régime russe l'a parfaitement compris
c'est-à-dire que le chef d'orchestre de
la propagande poutinienne depuis le
début du règne de Poutine qui s'appelle
sorcov et peut-être lu le match du
Kremlin
une théorise le chaos il théorise
l'expansion du chaos et cette fois-ci
pas dans une fiction mais dans un
véritable article de 2021
sorcoff à ce moment là il est
responsable de la politique ukrainienne
de Poutine quand même sur coffre
il explique que la seule manière pour la
Russie le régime russe de continuer à
exister c'est l'expansion du chaos pour
remédier phénomène récurrent des
tensions intérieures et donc le but
c'est l'extension du chaos le but de
cette propagande n'est pas d'être cru
mais elle est débranlée notre rapport à
la vérité de fait qu'on ne croit plus en
rien et qu'on soit en énervement
permanent et bien cette approche là
correspond magnifiquement aux
algorithmes des plateformes et donc en
fait on joue nous tout le temps sur un
terrain extérieur maman c'est comme si
on était une équipe de foot qui passait
son temps à jouer à l'extérieur alors
même que on bloquait tout l'accès à ces
plateformes et donc il joue à la maison
chez nous c'est aussi basique que ça
grâce à ses algorithmes puisque leur
approche correspond au terrain de jeu et
aux règles et aux lois du terrain de jeu
et donc là
[Musique]
enquêtes elles analysent ce que nous
faisons en ce moment et l'idée c'est
quand même de bâtir une coalition sans
les États-Unis sur cette question là
pour obliger les Américains à réfléchir
réellement à l'influence alors même que
quand même ils ont eu des images que
vous avez toutes et tous vu du Capitole
et que c'est une conséquence notamment
des algorithmes des des plateformes donc
il y a là un enjeu fondamental et
c'est pour ça que votre amendement était
fondamental
merci je vais pas reprendre ce qu'a dit
à Fabien que je partage un premier mot
sur
a-t-on dit pourquoi on suspendait où on
interdisait l'installation de Tik Tok
sur les outils des fonctionnaires
européens il faut voir que l'Union
européenne c'est à la fois un grand
marché et aussi une construction
juridique donc elle est toujours
extrêmement pointilleuse dans ce qu'elle
dit publiquement elle n'est pas toujours
très politique c'est loin qu'on puisse
dire elle le devient mais elle le
devient face aux crises et un peu dans
la douleur
celui qui est allé le plus loin dans
l'explication c'est l'organisme de
régulation belge qui a pris la même
décision que d'autres et qui a dit des
choses assez claires en disant Tik Tok
colle est une grande quantité de données
auprès des utilisateurs et peut
manipuler les flux d'information et de
contenu la loi chinoise Bleach Tik Tok a
coopérer avec les services de
renseignement chinois raison pour
laquelle on demande au fonctionnaires
belges de ne plus charger TikTok je vous
ai offert gratuitement la traduction
d'un communiqué qui est en néerlandais
et eux ils sont allés bah c'est
frontalement là où les autres ont été
plus vagues plus généraux alors est-ce
que c'est un défaut de mélanger Tik Tok
avec d'autres
paradoxalement je ne suis pas sûr je ne
suis pas sûr parce que ce qu'on reproche
à la Chine de faire au travers de son
outil à elle et Raphaël Luxman a raison
de dire c'est la pratique qui compte
Tik Tok est un outil de propagande et
d'influence de la Chine mais elle le
fait aussi à travers les autres
performes
elle le fait à travers twitter facebook
j'ai quelque part les chiffres pendant
la pandémie de covid de la manière dont
Twitter à essayer de courir après la
désinformation puisque c'était le
premier sujet sur lesquels les
plateformes admettaient que quand il y
avait une question de vie ou de mort
elles avaient une responsabilité et on y
reviendra sur le fait que à partir de là
ils ont admis qu'elle n'était pas
simplement des tuyaux mais qu'elles
avaient une responsabilité 2019
Twitter bloque
envir environ 500 faux comptes chinois
2020 je crois que c'est 130 000 et
quelques chiffres précis quelque part
donc l'influence la manipulation de
l'information elle passe à travers
toutes les plateformes
TikTok en études mais c'est loin d'être
la seule et je considère que l'approche
européenne qui considère qui souhaite
réguler toutes les plateformes c'est pas
une approche lâche qui ne veut pas voir
où est la difficulté c'est une approche
de précaution vis-à-vis de tous
et pour répondre à votre question sur
Clover d'abord la présentation qui en a
été faite et pour le moment extrêmement
flou on sait peu de choses on sait que
TikTok s'engage à avoir des centres de
données donc en Irlande et en Norvège
alors en Irlande on sait que c'est pour
des raisons fiscales il y a à peu près
pas de doute là-dessus dire que
l'Irlande ferme davantage les yeux que
d'autres c'est de moins en moins vrai
l'Autorité de régulation irlandaise
peut-être piquer au vif et aussi parce
qu'elle est armée aujourd'hui du rgpd et
du DSA fait son travail c'est elle qui a
déclenché deux procédures d'enquête sur
l'utilisation des données par TiK ToK on
va voir ce qu'elle devienne mais en tout
cas elle a l'obligation de le faire
aujourd'hui
en revanche quand Tik Tok nous dit
qu'ils vont avoir un audit indépendant
d'une entreprise de cybersécurité
qu'elle audit sur quel critère quelle
entreprise on connaissais rien et c'est
probablement pas suffisant pour être
rassuré
sur l'approche qui est celle de la
régulation donc celle qui a été prise
d'abord par le rgpd ensuite par le DSA
ça n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga c'est
pas les tables de la Loi gravées dans le
marbre mais c'est un premier pas
important intéressant justement parce
que s'agissant du DSA on est plus dans
la naïveté de dire les plateformes sont
des tuyaux elles n'ont pas de
responsabilité on les met devant le
responsabilité la Commission les
autorités de régulation des États
membres doivent avoir accès au Graal
c'est-à-dire aux algorithmes de
recommandations
les plateformes elles-mêmes ont des
responsabilités et là on n'est pas allé
assez loin c'est à elle en quelque sorte
de faire en sorte d'atténuer les risques
de contenu
préjudiciables quel qu'il soit
évidemment vraiment du thé contre les
contenus illégaux on a d'ailleurs ajouté
d'autres réglementations par exemple sur
les contenus terroristes pour leur
donner des obligations spécifiques on
travaille sur les contenus pédaux
pornographiques il y a eu une première
réglementation qui était j'allais dire
intérimaire pour éviter qu'on se
retrouve sans aucune réglementation et
maintenant on travaille sur une
réglementation plus durable c'est à nous
de donner des orientations sur ce qui
est illégal hors ligne qui doit devenir
complètement en ligne est-ce qu'on va
assez loin la vraie question le vrai
test maintenant pour les très grandes
plateformes pour lequel le DSA est déjà
en vigueur depuis quelques semaines
c'est notre capacité à faire respecter
cette réglementation c'est à dire à
enquêter à considérer qu'il y a eu une
brèche dans la réglementation et à
imposer les sanctions en sanctions qui
peuvent être très significatives puisque
elles sont de plusieurs pourcentages du
chiffre d'affaires mondial de ces
plateformes donc elles sont
véritablement
dissuasives à à mal se comporter et là
on entre dans le moment de test est-ce
que la commission dont c'est pas l'ADN
immédiat
je vais être capable de taper du point
sur la table et de dire là nous vous
avons vu vous avez été en violation du
DSA je dirais que le premier des tests
il est sur Twitter de Elon Musk
quand on voit ce que c'est que
l'effondrement de la modération de
Twitter quand on voit ce que sont
aujourd'hui les algorithmes de
recommandation de Twitter qui font que
vous avez sur votre fil les choses que
vous n'avez jamais sollicité il y a
évidemment une question à se poser
au-delà de la question à se poser il y a
un dialogue très ferme à avoir avec
Twitter et il y a à faire respecter par
Twitter comme Elon Musk avait un peu
rapidement promis le DJ tôle service at
c'est un vrai sujet c'est un vrai
instrument qui est sans doute pas le
dernier parce que la technologie va vite
mais je pense vraiment que
au-delà de la spécificité de Tik Tok les
ingérences étrangères notamment
chinoises passent par toutes les
plateformes et que si
on banni TikTok d'une certaine manière
ça renaîtra autrement et de toute façon
ça prendra d'autres canaux sur le
château des Spoutnik je partage tout à
fait ce que disait le président malgré
pour autant si on regarde les chiffres
de la désinformation d'origine russe
qui circule par des moyens numériques en
Europe depuis le l'interdiction de le
château des et de Spoutnik on a donné un
coup de pied dans la fourmilière et ça
s'est répandu par tout ailleurs c'est
extraordinairement compliqué de se dire
que la mesure comprend aussi
spectaculaire soit-elle est suffisante
par rapport au but qu'on
poursuit en revanche la notion de
récitrocité que on brandit toujours
quand on parle de la Chine et qu'on
applique peu parce que les Chinois
bannissent simplement de réciprocité
dans nos échanges devrait être au cœur
de nos échanges avec la Chine c'est à
dire que accepter une plateforme comme
Tik Tok et accepter que les plateformes
occidentales elles ne sont pas
représentées en Chine est un vrai sujet
c'est d'abord un sujet pour les
États-Unis puisqu'il n'y a pas de
plateforme européenne
et on voit bien la réponse américaine
qui est de dire on va peut-être bannir
Tik Tok tout simplement parce qu'il y a
pas de régulation américaine et qui a
une concurrence
économique commerciale entre les
plateformes américaines la sorte
chinoise qu'on regarde passer au dessus
de nos têtes on n'est pas exactement
dans la même position que les États-Unis
et les États-Unis se sont mis dans une
position où
la légitimité de leur préoccupations est
un peu ternie par
leur souci de gains ou de d'absence de
perte commerciale
on l'a dit aucune plateforme n'est
exemplaire c'est bien pour s'active toc
comme les autres doit passer par le DSA
quel est l'accès des Chinois à Tik Tok
non il y a un Tik Tok spécial Chine
qui est encore plus contrôlé encore plus
verrouillé que que le véritable Tik Tok
mais Tik Tok sert évidemment à des
publics occidentaux surtout jeunes c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons qui a fait
que dans le DJ Jon service Act il y a
des mesures particulières de protection
des mineurs qui sont demandées aux
plateformes notamment aux très grandes
plateformes à la fois de protection des
données protection sur les contenus
quand vous êtes une très grande
plateforme qui que vous soyez vis-à-vis
des mineurs vous avez plus de
responsabilité
sur les contenus pornographiques je l'ai
dit l'Europe travaille d'abord et avant
tout sur le contenu pedo pornographique
pour leur faire la chasse toutes les
plateformes quelle que soit leur
nationalité vont vous dire que c'est
très compliqué que ces techniquesment
infaisable c'est tout à fait faisable
techniquement simplement ça coûte de
l'argent et nous nous leur disons à
l'inverse que ne pas le faire ça leur
coûte en réputation et de ce point de
vue là ça fonctionne assez bien et je
dirais que sur les contenus pédaux
pornographiques un certain nombre de
plateformes ont mis au point des outils
qu'il faut évidemment contrôler pour
être sûr qu'ils ne sont pas intrusifs
sur notre vie privée mais on a un vrai
débat au Parlement européen et parfois
certains citrons étant tellement
préoccupés par la protection de la vie
privée qui serait prêt à protéger les
pédocrinels
après ils le font et d'ailleurs ils le
font et les plateformes de ce point de
vue là sont plutôt du côté de ceux qui
veulent lutter contre la pédophile parce
qu'ils ont bien compris le risque
réputationnel auquel ils sont exposés
c'est là où on voit toute l'ambiguïté du
dialogue on peut avoir avec
merci madame la Présidente merci à vous
deux j'étais particulièrement sensible
aux propos que vous avez tenu aux
analyses que vous faites de la
situation pour travailler depuis 10 ans
au sein de notre commission des affaires
européennes sur ces sujets qui sont en
fait des sujets de souveraineté
numérique pour lesquelles d'ailleurs
j'avais l'occasion à la ministre de vous
rencontrer
à l'époque je partage complètement ce
qui vient d'être dit nous avons péché
par naïveté encore trop longtemps je me
souviens qu'en pleine affaire Cambridge
Analytica nous déroulons les visées
déroulent le tapis rouge à Mark
Zuckerberg qui vient en grande pompe en
visite à Paris sans qu'on en fasse le
moindre commentaire sur ce qui est en
train de se jouer et de se passer qui
était très très grave en fait il aura
peut-être fallu attendre finalement la
crise sanitaire et la guerre aux portes
de l'Europe pour vraiment se réveiller
bon c'est tant mieux vaut mieux tard que
que jamais mais il faut aussi être dans
une rigueur une exigence absolue quand
vous évoquez le pantouflage et le resto
pant
vous parlez beaucoup des élus et des
ministres mais je voudrais signaler
quand même que il y a beaucoup de
fonctionnaires et haut fonctionnaires
qui pratiquent intensivement le
pantouflage et le rétropontouflage en
France en Europe et qui gangrène en
quelque sorte voilà
tout tout ça et que on aurait intérêt
peut-être à trouver les voies et les
manières de de répondre à cette cette
problématique
je voulais revenir
madame Loiseau sur la question des
plateformes mais je vous remercie de
prendre de la hauteur et nous dire qu'il
y a la question de TikTok
particulièrement liée à l'état
autoritaire l'État chinois mais il y a
l'ensemble des plateformes par
lesquelles elle transite et l'affaire
Cambridge a été k montre que les
plateformes ont des failles et
introduisent volontairement des bagues
d'ours et se laisse donc du coup presque
manipuler
dans la mesure où ça permet aussi de
faire du du profit flanchisoguen nous
l'a bien dit elle nous a dit ce sera
toujours la le profit au détriment de la
de la sécurité donc je réinsister
puisque nous avons travaillé avec
plusieurs collègues sur les des rapports
et des propositions de résolution
européenne sur le DSA mais aussi plus
récemment avec André gatelin sur
l'intelligence artificielle parce que le
règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle va permettre aussi de
réguler indirectement ces ces
plateformes ces outils et ses
applications
croyez-vous possible à l'heure actuelle
de faire vivre cette idée d'une vraie
responsabilité comme la suggérer Claude
malurer des plateformes quel que soit
leur origine la notion de de
redevabilité et de
comment dirais et de responsabilité
parce que somme toute la faiblesse du
DSA c'est quand même qu'on renvoie aux
plateformes la capacité à faire
elle-même c'est assez dangereux aussi
pour la liberté d'expression on a vu
l'effet de Twitter qui interdit le
compte de Donald Trump voilà et donc
pensez ez-vous que ce débat peut se
poursuivre parce que je pense que c'est
la clé en fait du du sujet nous avons
précisé d'ailleurs dans dans le
règlement sur l'IA et sur le DSA toutes
ces questions en tout cas dans des
rapports que que nous avons fait voilà
je vous remercie donc de pouvoir nous
répondre sur sur ce sujet
merci madame la Présidente merci à vous
deux on a l'occasion de s'auto
auditionné parfois sur des sujets ce qui
montre que tout se recoupe moi j'ai une
question alors je sais que c'est pas le
travail ni de la commission ni du
Parlement européen mais semble-t-il
aucune institution c'est de s'intéresser
à l'entreprise Tic-Toc dans sa structure
quel est son business model ce qui
m'intéresse dans une entreprise qui
connaît un tel développement c'est de
savoir à quoi sert Tik Tok au-delà
évidemment de produire des
divertissements éventuellement de
l'abrutissement ou du jeu des extrêmes
et ça fait déjà quelques temps que
j'essaye de comprendre d'avoir des
données économiques sur Tik Tok et son
fonctionnement heureusement on en a à
travers les États-Unis parce qu'il y a
des choses comme l'audience de toute
façon il faut bien présenter des données
d'audience on a quelques éléments
concernant les revenus publicitaires
mais la conclusion à laquelle j'en suis
actuellement c'est que Tik Tok n'est pas
une entreprise rentable et qu'elle n'a
pas les bases de sa rentabilité
les seules ressources qu'elle a côté
occidental c'est la publicité
la publicité marche assez mal sur TikTok
alors bien sûr il y a une progression
des revenus publicitaires vu la
progression exponentielle mais de
l'audience mais à un niveau bien moindre
que WhatsApp ou de tout un tas d'autres
systèmes d'autant que inclure des
messages publicitaires d'un des
programmes extrêmement courts conduit à
faire baisser l'audience ce qui est noté
d'ailleurs par les analystes américains
là où il y a eu de la publicité
j'ai du mal à comprendre effectivement
la structure avec by dance by dance à
150 000 personnes d'après mes calculs il
y a pas de chiffre d'employés de Tik Tok
mais il y en a au moins 30 000 pour
faire tourner quand j'ai 30000 c'est
assez peu et en fait il y a la partie
effectivement chinoise
doing qui est celle qui rapporte de
l'argent qui est d'ailleurs reconnaît en
ce moment
on arrête sa progression parce que elle
a un système de plateforme et devant en
ligne ce que n'a pas Tik Tok à
l'international et le fondée sur des
programmes totalement différents j'en
arrive à cette question c'est quelle est
la richesse réelle de Tik Tok ou de là
de sa marque mais la valorisation de sa
marque ça veut pas dire grand-chose si
c'est pas les recettes publicitaires ce
sont ces données les données massives
qu'elle obtient sur les personnes des
données ça se valorise soit d'un point
de vue publicitaire compris en termes de
publicité ciblée ce que ne fait pas
TikTok en tous les cas dans la partie
occidentale ça se valorise pour
développer un algorithme alors ça oui il
l'utilise puis des données
logiquement ça peut se revendre ce
qu'ils ne font pas donc quand je regarde
la stratégie du gouvernement chinois et
ça nous a été confirmé par les services
nous sommes tous les jours dans les pays
européens américains payés sur des bases
de données personnelles de nos services
publics avec des moyens d'infraction
comment le gouvernement chinois se
priverait des données concernant plus
d'un milliard d'utilisateurs très
précises dans le reste du monde c'est à
dire que la question du transfert des
données
légale ou pas légal doit bien exister
puisque c'est une source d'information
la deuxième chose qu'est-ce qu'on fait
c'est donner une fois qu'elles sont
prises le temps de conservation des
données on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui
quand l'Italie a décidé en tout cas le
régulateur italien a décidé de suspendre
provisoirement tchat j'ai pity c'était
précisément sur la question du respect
ou pas du règlement personnel et aussi
des âges de consentement et chaque
député a dit nous allons relancer la
production avec beaucoup moins de
données personnelles et avec moins
d'historique sur les personnes l'usage
de l'intelligence artificielle notamment
sur la base des données pose cette
question de combien de temps garde-t-on
des données c'est pas simplement où les
stockons ou les analystes et là-dessus
on n'a pas d'éléments alors est-ce que
l'approche économique vous paraît une
approche fiable parce que si on veut
comprendre ce qu'est Tik Tok et à quoi
ça sert
[Musique]
ou les grands groupes numériques
internationaux
dernière année collègues ont demandé à
poser une question Rémi Cardon après je
vous laisserai répondre et conclure et
nous serons arrivés une heure
raisonnable pour lever cette séance
merci madame la Présidente effectivement
une question avec une mise en contexte
ça a été dit
on doit aussi tout se poser la question
de pas que se focaliser sur Tik Tok
parce que en fait si on en regarde
l'ancienneté les plateformes américaines
se sont installées et le business model
que tu viens de définir chaque collègue
en réalité c'est la recherche de
volumétrie en termes d'utilisateur pour
s'installer dans une société et après
jouer sur des campagnes d'influence
c'est ça le modèle le business model et
puis par la suite on a vu les évolutions
de Facebook Instagram et autres là tout
de suite
d'être en mesure de vendre de la
publicité parce qu'il y a une volumétrie
très intéressante et donc ça se business
model il est déguisé aussi simple que
manque comme ça et c'est pour ça que ça
mériterait quand même de regarder de
près le l'entreprise en comment elle
fonctionne parce que je pense qu'on a on
n'a pas forcément vu le vent venir sur
sur d'autres entreprises américaines et
maintenant on
on est dans un bras de fer un peu
compliqué
moi je vais revenir sur le DSA puisque
il rentre en vigueur en septembre 2023
avec tout un travail qui va être fait
j'espère dans les prochains mois au
Parlement en français
en particulier sur la PPL influenceur
qui est en cours de d'analyse et puis
sur sur d'autres textes qui va
arriveront prochainement mais je
m'interroge sur le les moyens qui vont
être mis en face c'est à dire on a
l'habitude de d'installer la loi
et puis les ETP à la recom est-ce que
ils vont être aussi conséquent de
l'ampleur du sujet parce que on peut se
dire les choses on peut on peut essayer
de faire peur d'ailleurs en fait la
Commission européenne vous l'avez dit
dans la question du pourquoi fait
essentiellement de la prévention
en mettant un coup en disant voilà les
fonctionnaires n'auront pas le droit
d'utiliser Tik Tok et hausse c'est aussi
un on va dire une espèce de coup de
pression dans le bras de fer mais et
pour préparer et il y a aussi une idée
de prévention là dedans mais en soit ils
l'ont pas fait pour les autres
c'est-à-dire c'est une vraie question je
vais pas souvenir peut-être que j'étais
trop jeune mais j'ai pas souvenir que ça
a été fait pour d'autres plateformes
donc il y a quand même une vraie
question qu'on doit se poser aussi c'est
à dire que pourquoi Tik Tok pour que pas
d'autres la question qu'on peut toutes
et tous s'interroger c'est
le fait que on a très tardivement une
connaissance assez fine les algorithmes
et parfois il est trop tard il est trop
tard parce qu'ils sont tellement
puissants en termes de volumétrie et le
seul pour avoir fait un rapport sur la
super sécurité le seul volet sur lequel
en techniquement on doit s'interroger
c'est pas forcément la cybersécurité en
tant que tel de la de l'application
c'est
le fait de pas connaître effectivement
le savon ça a été dit la porte un peu
dérobée
de ne pas avoir tout le cheminement
derrière
et de pas avoir la main là-dessus en
tout cas une certaine visibilité ça peut
nous amener effectivement à des enjeux
géopolitiques ça a été très bien précisé
avant et pour le coup on est vraiment en
réalité j'ai bien j'ai bien peur que on
peut être il y a plusieurs questions
mais je rebondis aussi sur des questions
précédentes c'était pour appuyer les
propos de mes collègues mais voilà
non mais
vous avez raison sur le pantouflage
aussi sur les hauts fonctionnaires moi
je suis pas à l'aise de voir que le
président de Huawei France est l'ancien
patron de Polytechnique très clairement
avec son réseau son carnet d'adresse
alors comment on fait quand les gens
sont en retraite
est-ce qu'on peut faire en sorte qu'il
s'engage avant de prendre sa fonction
dans leur vie active à ne pas en prendre
d'autres en nommant les choses comme le
disait Raphaël Gluckman c'est pas la
même chose de travailler pour une
entreprise norvégienne que de travailler
pour une entreprise chinoise en tout cas
c'est une piste qui mérite vraiment
d'être creusée elle est dans le projet
de rapport que je présente au Parlement
européen en ce moment
sur la responsabilité des plateformes
pour moi le DSA est une étape
avant le DSA on avait juste un Code de
bonnes pratiques où on confiait
entièrement aux plateformes
sur le
principe de leur bonne foi le rôle de
s'auto réguler le DSA prend la main et
demande à un certain nombre de choses
aux plateformes leur donne des
obligations de moyens et aussi de
résultats il peut les sanctionner si les
résultats ne sont pas là c'est pas
suffisant de mon point de vue simplement
ça n'est pas non plus
tout à fait choquant qu'on avance pas à
pas dans la mesure où on est malgré tout
sur une question de liberté d'expression
et où je ne voudrais pas qu'on se
précipite aujourd'hui on est l'Europe
est entre deux contre modèles le Far
West américain la loi de la jungle et
l'hyper contrôle chinoise on invente une
troisième voie qui me semble-t-il à
l'avantage de la raison et de la finesse
évitons d'avoir la main trop lourde
sachant que même en Europe certains
parmi ce qu'on appelle poliment les
démocraties il libérales voudraient nous
pousser à contrôler Internet bien
davantage avec des arrière-pensées sur
lesquelles il faut être aussi assez
précautionneux donc pour moi c'est une
étape par la dernière
mais une étape donc le vrai test c'est
notre capacité c'est la capacité de la
Commission à frapper du toit sur la
table à faire un exemple pour dire les
choses et à sanctionner financièrement
mas une plateforme qui aurait dérapé
c'est donc la question des moyens pour
répondre à la question qui a été posée
naturellement il faut en nombre et en
compétences les gens suffisants à la
fois au niveau de la Commission et des
autorités nationales pour être capable
de poursuivre des plateformes qui
elles-mêmes sont blindées de juristes
tous publié brillants les uns que les
autres mieux payer les uns que les
autres et ça sera pas extraordinairement
simple mais je pense que il y a
aujourd'hui dès maintenant matière à
redresser le fonctionnement de certaines
plateformes par stage pas l'idée selon
lequel c'est trop tard de connaître un
algorithme non parce qu'on peut toujours
demander la modification sur des vraies
raisons et le fait que maintenant il est
accès aux algorithmes que les chercheurs
est accès à des données c'est quand même
une vraie révolution par rapport à
quelque chose contre quoi les
plateformes ont tout fait pour que ça
n'ait pas lieu et je peux vous dire que
le lobbying des plateformes
la négociation du DSA a été ce que vous
pouvez imaginer comme il l'avait été
pour le pour le rgpd et elles n'ont pas
eu gains de cause même si on aurait sans
doute pu aller déjà plus loin mais je
pense qu'on a déjà fait un pas sur le
business model je partage ce qui a été
dit c'est-à-dire que on avait dit la
même chose de Twitter on dit toujours la
même chose de toute plateforme qui
démarre on dit mais enfin pas de sens
elle perd de l'argent jusqu'au moment où
elle en perd plus le but c'est de
saturer l'espace c'est à ça que sert
aussi le DM le digestion Market qui
consiste à traiter différentes non ce
qu'on appelle les guides Keepers pardon
je jargonne mais ceux qui précisément
risquent d'empêcher d'autres d'arriver
sur le marché des plateformes ce qu'on
constate en tout cas c'est que jusqu'à
présent l'Europe est toujours absente de
ce débat c'est qu'il y a aucune
entreprise européenne qui fasse le poids
et puis toujours sur le stockage des
données
juste un mot quand même
d'une part
malgré tout Tik Tok a commencé à bouger
après avoir fait après avoir vu les
décisions des institutions européennes
non pardon avant avoir vu les décisions
institutions européennes quand il y a eu
les TikTok clicks il y a eu une
opération d'un match control le patron
de TikTok a fait le tour de la
Commission à Bruxelles ça n'a pas
extrêmement bien marché puisque il a
suffi qu'il vienne pour que la
Commission et le Parlement décide que on
le sortait des
des outils des fonctionnaires il n'a pas
dû être ultra convaincant
donc maintenant on entend parler du
projet Clover et on voit que il pourrait
y avoir des stockages de données en
Europe mais c'est juste l'application du
rgpd en fait
c'est à dire que le patron de Tik Tok
c'est fait expliquer par la Commission
européenne tous ceux vis-à-vis de quoi
il était en violation c'est un petit
début mais c'est quand même quelque
chose ça ne suffira peut-être pas mais
ça veut tout de même dire je le pense
que si on a le courage d'aller au-delà
de l'adoption de règle mais qu'on se
concentre sur leur mise en oeuvre on a
un levier parce qu'on est 450 millions
de consommateurs parce que Tik Tok
aujourd'hui c'est on sait pas très bien
125 150 millions d'utilisateurs en
Europe c'est à dire autant qu'aux
États-Unis et donc par définition Tik
Tok doit prendre en compte ce qui va lui
être dit par l'Union européenne bon
courage au Britannique qui ont quitté
l'Union européenne
merci madame la Présidente merci pour
vos questions je vais essayer de pas
répéter ce qui vient d'être dit
juste sur le compte flash évidemment
le problème que ça pose c'est que c'est
les réseaux c'est la connaissance
et ensuite c'est la suspicion qui est
nécessairement née dans l'opinion c'est
à dire quand ces personnes étaient en
poste est-ce qu'il travaillait déjà pour
leur futur employeur c'est une question
légitime c'est pas du complotisme là par
contre c'est une question légitime qui
est éveillée par ce type de bascule qui
devient extrêmement fréquent et qui
doit être combattu parce que là j'ai
l'impression que la leçon a été tirée
pour la Russie donc on a poussé les
anciens dignitaires qui se livraient à
ce genre de pratique avec les grandes
entreprises russes à démissionné des
bornes mais personne ne semble avoir
fait le lien avec la Chine et avec
d'autres régimes
la responsabilité des plateformes alors
je partage tout ça fait ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est un premier pas et tout
dépend de la manière dont l'application
on a une expérience en Europe d'avoir
des textes qui souvent sont
progressistes et qui ouvre des nouvelles
voies mais dont l'application laisse à
désirer et et il va falloir qu'on fasse
nous tous alors là à l'échelle nationale
et à l'échelle européenne attention à la
manière dont sont appliqués les textes
qui ont été votés
les autorités
et la Commission et donc le problème qui
se pose justement là je vais y venir
parce que là en ce moment même au
Parlement européen moi je suis en train
de négocier sur le bannissement des
produits de l'esclavage donc dire ça à
l'avoir mais l'enjeu est en fait le
système c'est le même c'est-à-dire que
le texte va être bon j'en suis sûr on va
trouver un compromis et ça va être un
texte très important qui va ouvrir un
nouveau champ
la grande question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour que ce soit appliqué de
manière à peu près harmonieuse à
l'échelle de 27 États membres donc il
faut que la Commission ait une
responsabilité donc nous
au Parlement on explique à la commission
il faut qu'elle arrête d'être timide et
qu'elle accepte d'avoir une
responsabilité plus forte que ce qui a
aujourd'hui écrit dans le texte le
problème c'est que vous regardez les
gens avec des cernes qui vous parlent et
qui vous explique qui sont cinq pour
contrôler l'ensemble des ports du
continent européen et par ailleurs voir
si par
les milles et les deux personnes qui
parlent chinois et bien ils ont
peut-être 5 minutes de libre pour savoir
s'il y a pas du dumping quelque part
donc en fait il y a un vrai problème là
qui est qu'on passe des textes qui sont
extrêmement importants pour protéger de
l'espace européen en général et que
l'Union européenne contrairement à la
propagande des nationalistes et sous
dotés
et qu'on a un vrai problème de faiblesse
du budget européen et de faiblesse des
instances de contrôle à l'échelle
européenne on
parle là de compétences qui sont en
train de s'agrandir et ont tout le monde
demande de plus en plus de choses à
l'Union européenne et il est évident que
si on veut protéger l'espace numérique
on va pas le faire à l'échelle de la
France seule si on veut protéger le
marché des produits de l'esclavage ou de
la déforestation on va pas le faire à
l'échelle de la France seule mais on va
confier de plus en plus de tâches à une
administration qui est celle d'un
village et ça va être compliqué tu vois
je vais vous dire ça va être compliqué
de faire face aux armées de lobbyistes
ou de ou de d'avocats des grandes
plateformes comme ça va être compliqué
sur la question des produits qui
rentrent sur notre marché
la question de l'objectif et de la
nature de l'entreprise
comme toutes ces plateformes évidemment
ça a été dit le but c'est d'abord de
s'installer de de se répandre et ensuite
peut-être de valoriser
sa place dominante
la question qui se pose c'est que là on
est dans les dans le moment de
l'expansion et pas encore tout à fait de
la valorisation
et comme on est
est je reviens à mon point de départ
dans un système un écosystème
ou pour reprendre les termes d'un
éditorial de Riha Novosti
l'agence officielle russe l'argent n'est
pas tout à propos de gastronome
il y a une vraie question quand même qui
se pose c'est à dire que
s'étendre ça veut dire collecter le plus
possible de donner ça veut dire occuper
un espace dominant si on est dans le
même temps au service d'un régime
politique dans les intérêts et les
principes sont fondamentalement hostiles
au domaine dans lequel on s’étend ça
pose une question c'est à dire que
qu'est-ce qui va être à la fin considéré
comme la véritable valorisation des
efforts qui sont produits actuellement
est-ce que c'est vendre des pubs et donc
faire du fric pour être très basique ou
est-ce que c'est une autre forme de
valorisation des données qu'on collecte
c'est à dire une valorisation d'essence
plus politiques et dans ce cas là ça
pose un danger plus grand pour la
sécurité de nos nations voilà j'ai pas
besoin en tout cas je vous remercie et
j'espère que on a pu vous aider dans
votre entreprise salutaire
je vous remercie tous les deux d'être
venu et de la qualité et de la précision
de vos propos et des réponses que vous
avez apportées à la fois questionnaire
qui vous avez été adressé aux questions
composées dessinateurs et sénatrices
présents cet après-midi merci